a new harris poll says that only one in
three americans say that they're happy
which would explain all the
antidepressant commercials on TV let's
take a look at some numbers happiness so
yeah thirty-three percent this is the
happiness index as you can see on our
very fancy card thirty-three percent of
americans say they're happy happiness
levels are fairly high during youth they
get a little less when you're in your
40s they increase again in the mid 50's
peaking later in life probably the
minute before you die optimism
sixty-seven percent of respondents say
that they were optimistic about the
future as compared to 75 percent in 2011
so that's dropping and optimum optimism
levels in the US are significantly below
the global average eighty-nine percent
of citizens internationally feel that
the future will be as good or better
than their present situation so this
seems actually pretty in line with
everything we hear all the time that
this generation of young people is going
to be worse off than their parents for
the first time in American history and
it's just being so ingrained in us that
America seems dunzo kind of is America
over and are we truly less happy and
have a worse outlook these are difficult
numbers and we must sift through them
first of all the global average of
eighty-nine percent of people in the
world think that the war the future will
be as good or better there's like a
billion people who don't have toilets
exactly so how much worse could it get I
think that's just kind of
self-fulfilling that it has to be better
right are they going to take away my not
a toilet right oh no we're gonna take
away my hole and we're saying you know
can I get PlayStation 4 make it up so we
have a pretty good also this is people
saying they're very happy and to be
honest I hate those people people like
oh it's so good today isn't it a gift
yeah I just want to smack a shakedown
yeah so that's that's my time happiness
Fred how happy are you on a day to day
basis how important is a penis in the in
the fred Karger operation I think it's
very important of course and as a gay
activist has been interesting as I've
talked to a lot of parents particularly
those with LGBT kids and I've asked them
what what do you want
your kids for your kids and that number
one thing is to be happy I think that's
so ingrained in us it's important and
put everything else aside that's kind of
the bottom line and their varying
degrees of happiness and you can't be
this very happy mood all the time it's a
roller coaster so I think it's good i
think the question i have in the studies
of course you can depend on how the
questions are asked can be all over the
place but I don't know people get that
much happier with age I think there's a
lot of depression with older people as
they're left aside in the world but I
think it's good and Brett says this is
important it's all relative what is
considered happy we're so fortunate in
this country to live in this this nation
when you go around the world see
everybody lined up at our consulates who
want to come here just fact that we're
in this country with these freedoms that
we don't have in places like China we're
very fortunate just be happy yeah one of
the things that I thought was
fascinating this poll is that they show
that in Israel they're much happier than
us which seems bizarre because they're
surrounded by enemies their bombs going
off all kinds of other stuff so maybe
it's it's our excess and all of our
freedoms that in a weird way make us not
happy is that possible that we don't
have existential threats so we can be
worrying about nonsensical things all
the time yeah I'm watching the sopranos
again and little AJ has everything and
look at me did we give them too much is
what Tony and Carmela asked themselves
all the time maybe that is it I just
think if there's also like a complaining
culture on the rise where it's just nice
it makes you feel happy to complain and
then there's a politeness issue where if
you just rub it in people's face how
happy you are I the fact that two out of
three people aren't that happy kind of
makes me happy so we can all take solace
in that maybe the two of the three of us
who were like sad about it and we'll be
happy again and maybe then we'll all be
happy yeah do you guys think that maybe
happiness is overrated as part of
humanity like no other species on earth
you know they eat and they die and they
kill and you know make babies but we are
constantly under this pressure that we
have to be happy I always think when i
was doing stand-up all the time when I
just started I was really struggling and
I no money and i was working shitty gigs
doing all this awful stuff people always
used to say to me well as long as you're
happy
and always thought it was crazy like why
should I be happy I'm trying to follow
my dream get these hanging out with drug
addicts alcoholics why should I have the
burden of happy happiness is can be a
weird bird into can it as opposed to
just living some sort of even-keeled
slightly depressed operation would that
be easier it's this work being sure it's
a lot of work and we all live that life
that's up and down and that's a that's
important to realize would take
advantage of the happy times and and
just know that you want to live a good
life be good other people that's my
measure of happiness when that you close
your eyes for the last time it's like
what kind of life did you live where
your good person and so I think that's
that's happiness yeah I definition
alright so final thought on happiness
because like we can't talk about
happiness without talking about the
prescription drug situation because you
turn on the TV and literally every
commercial is a sad cartoon chasing a
man around all day in another man who
can't get direction another man who's
bald and they all have horrific side
effects including depression and death
and all that kind of stuff but is this
again because we put so much pressure on
ourselves being happy that we're taking
drugs that are making a suicidal us not
happy that we take another drug because
now you can take an Billa fly which you
know works with the other thing and blah
blah blah happiness and drugs you do I
think we've always been kind of
depressed I feel because look at the
amount and this is just we now have
drugs that can help us as opposed to
like getting on top of it not just you
know there's a fire there's a line of
mental illness and and and that kind of
thing which is like official and
clinical that you know I don't want to
get into but like there's definitely
that fringe where people like just give
me some zoloft or something but that
said the American Dream is come to this
country you'll have freedom awesome your
children will have freedom great and you
just work hard every day and wait a
minute go back to that I have to work
hard and in that is an implied struggle
and I think that explains well in the
middle of your life you're just pretty
sad because you have to work so hard and
hopefully by the end when you're retired
you know the work is hard then then you
get your free to be happy but there is a
streaming in every narrative of the
American dream there is struggle and
struggle is not the happiest time of
your life
and on that note I hope we've added a
little happiness to your life this week
that's fred Karger that's brett erlich
i'm dave rubin we do this every week
there's like buttons and subscribe
things and all kinds of other buttons
just click on press them whatever you
got to do and we'll see you next week
thanks